[Music]
if your crops look like they need a
miracle you're not alone but you can
Thrive even in drought drought can be
tough but Nigerian farmers are tougher
start by using drought resistant seeds
they need less water and still produce
good yields next practice mulching cover
your soil with leaves or straw to keep
moisture in and weeds out don't forget
to use efficient irrigation methods like
drip irrigation it delivers water
directly to plant roots saving water and
increasing growth consider planting
crops like Millet and sorum they're
drought resistant and packed with
nutrients also build soil Health with
Organic Matter compost and manure
improve soil's water retention finally
stay informed join local farming groups
or follow agricultural updates to learn
new techniques remember drought doesn't
mean defeat with these tips you can
still achieve a Bountiful Harvest happy
farming